Beijing's launched its biggest-ever military drills in the Taiwan Strait...
...following Nancy Pelosi's visit to the self-governing island,...
...but it's also hit Taiwan with a new set of sanctions.
China suspended exports of natural sand...
...without much of an explanation.
Official Chinese data shows 90% of Taiwan's natural sand imports...
...came from China in 2007.
The material is used widely for construction and concrete.
China has also stopped imports of citrus fruit,...
...chilled white striped hairtail and frozen horse mackerel.
It's said it found pesticide residue on the fruit...
...and coronavirus traces on the frozen fish packaging.
The suspension hits one of China's top food imports from Taiwan: seafood.
In January to June, China imported 59 million dollars' worth of it from Taiwan.
Beijing also targeted 35 Taiwanese exporters of biscuits and pastries.
It's unclear if more sanctions are looming,...
...but Taiwan's biggest exports to China by value...
...are electronics, machinery, plastics and chemicals.
According to Chinese import data,...
...China's imports from Taiwan reached 122.5 billion dollars in January to June,...
...up more than 7% from a year earlier.